[Music]  so  every 9 11 member all across this nation  the first lady and i come to this  hallowed ground  deeply aware that we cannot fill the  void in your heart  or erase the terrible sorrow of this day  the agony renewed the nightmare relived  the wounds reopened the last treasured  words played over and over  again in your minds but while we cannot  erase your pain  we can help to shoulder your burden  our sacred task our righteous duty  and our solemn pledge is to carry  forward the noble legacy of the brave  souls  who gave their lives for us 19 years ago  in their memory we resolve to stand  united as one american nation  to defend our freedoms to uphold our  values  to love our neighbors to cherish our  country  to care for our communities to honor our  heroes  and to never ever forget  [Music]  william f fallon  and my father firefighter robert j  crawford  safety battalion one